i'm here with karina what do you do here
at Khan Academy I'm Khan Academy's
office manager so that means I do a
little bit of everything in the office
and I keep everybody happy I keep our
office stocked and filled with food and
snacks and our technology working and I
help our new hires and I help people in
need and basically anything and
everything that comes up during the day
somehow ends up on my desk so it's a
little sprinkle of everything here hello
if you weren't here we would just fall
apart yes basically that's the short
version that's the and what's what's
like your day to day what's a typical
day like or is there a typical day there
is usually not a typical day most of the
time I am I mean I come in and I do kind
of my first round of checking the office
make sure that nobody's burned anything
down or caused the massive destruction
so what that's happened some of that has
happened I have walked into 55 million
speckles of rice on a brand new table so
that was really exciting yes yeah one of
our team members Kyle yes who's very
enthusiastic one visualize what 5
million is yes yes he's also burned a
gummy bear on a table outside causing
some anxiety to two people passing by so
I like to make sure nothing major has
happened Alicia was rice and at least it
was just a gummy bear yes yeah hopefully
we don't continue to escalate um but
then I I kind of get to it you know
people normally send me and lots of
questions and inquiries over the night
you know things that they've come across
and I have a giant list of to do's that
things are constantly getting added to
and with our big company meetings
there's always something to plan and
prepare and get ready it's literally
everything I mean people might imagine
office manager keep the office
functioning which you do very well but
it's also things like our weekly update
with a company you plan a lot of events
for our team which it's a whole bunch of
things exactly yeah so I'm you know
helping run the AV for our company
update our weekly def stand up our
weekly devspeak now series any team
stands for development yes yes
sorry that's my term of endearment for
the devs it's a lot of times it pelipper
yeah exactly asked that I got a lot of
things to do everyone has a nickname
here so yeah I mean basically any big
event that's happening at Khan Academy I
somehow have a little hand in and what
were you doing before this before this I
was doing operations for a start-up in
San Francisco called trade shift and
very similar role you know helping
manage their offices here in San
Francisco and we have an office in
London and Copenhagen and we were
expanding so I got to test the waters of
how office culture works across the
globe which was really exciting and what
was your you know what wow did you hear
about Khan Academy why did you want to
be part of this I heard about Khan
Academy because I was looking for
something closer to home and I was very
excited to find his home homeless san
jose and so i was working in san
francisco which is very far from home so
i was excited to find out Khan Academy
was local was close to me I had no idea
that you guys were in this area and I
wanted a job that was personally
fulfilling I was a sociology major in
college and I care a lot about that what
the job I'm doing makes an impact on the
world in some way and same with the
company i'm working forth and I'm not
just you know punching and punching out
and helping put a big check in someone
else's pocket that you know I'm really
helping create an impact and that's
really what drove me here and I was very
very excited when I got the response
from Kayla that I could come in for an
interview and I knew as soon as I could
come in I was like I'm gonna nail this
we're very glad you did yeah and and
what and what advice would you have for
someone who wants to be an office
manager kind of follow in your footsteps
you know I think you have to be very
open in the tech industry in offices
this isn't a traditional office where
you come in and you're just filing
papers and Stocking pencils I mean your
job includes so many random and crazy
things I mean we had an instance where
we were celebrating a big launch and we
needed a hundred party poppers like
right away in 20 minutes so it's
something you have to be willing to kind
of be on your feet think fast be dynamic
and also be very agile be willing to do
many different things interact with
different groups
just keep your mind open because that's
how you're going to grow and move
farther in your career well thank you so
much greater we're we're so glad you're
here thanks Alf me too